everything annoyingly so comes down to  consistency showing up putting in the  work over and over and the systematic is  like every time you do something okay  what went well let's do a little bit  more of that well it didn't go so well  okay what are we going to try  differently you still got to show up and  be consistent how do you become the type  of person who's showing up and I think  this really comes back to one just like  living life with a sense of curiosity  but also like what is your why what is  your mission what is that thing that's  going to cause you to stay consistent to  stick it out to pull through when you  put something out there and not a single  person views it what's going to allow  you to push through a breaking through  is the sense of mission the sense of  curiosity